diesen sonntag also laufen die
bisherigen strengen schutzmaßnahmen aus
mir zugeschaltet ist jetzt der virologe
und veterinärmediziner dr klaus stöhr
guten abend herr stöhr
sie vertreten die position dass die
aufrechterhaltung der maßnahmen die
erkrankungen nur nach hinten verschieben
das lässt sich doch nur halten weil auch
mikron in den meisten fällen einen
milden verlauf hat oder wie darf ich sie
da verstehen ja ich glaub mir den
letzten tausend jahren alle 30 jahre
bandelin und die sind alle auf die einen
die ein und dieselbe art zu ende
gegangen nämlich dass sich alle
infiziert haben es gibt kein weg vorbei
familie ist eine situation bei der union
entsteht das sich nicht stoppen lässt an
der quelle was sich ausbreitet alle
infiziert das ist bei dieser pandemie
nicht anders also wer jetzt da
überrascht es dass eine durchleuchtung
eintritt die letzten zwei jahre im
tiefschlaf verbracht und die situation
tritt ja sein dass auch nikon wäre oder
delta oder wie auch immer dann die
nächste variante heißt irgendwann wäre
es zur durchleuchtung und zur
vollständigen infektionen kommen da geht
kein weg vorbei die maßnahmen dagegen
liegt jetzt auf dem tisch was besseres
kommt jetzt nicht es gibt eine tolle
impfung die hat nebenwirkung fraglos
aber sie ist schon vor allen dingen für
die über 60 jährigen genau das mittel
der wahl um dich auf die erstinfektion
vorzubereiten es gibt medikamente für
all diejenigen die sich impfen lassen
können wurde die nächtigungen pro tag
und dann gibt es ein stabiles
gesundheitswesen dass er wird es nicht
jetzt gibt es keine andere möglichkeit
mehr bis zum ende der pandemie zu kommen
als mit diesen
instrumenten wie sind nicht 100 prozent
wirksam es wird immer wieder infektionen
erkrankung und auch zugegeben ohne frage
das ist wie bei anderen
atemwegserkrankungen jetzt sind jetzt
müssen langsam aber eben die
verantwortung dieses lebensrisiko corona
zu dem eben zu begegnen muss in die
hände der menschen die zurückgelangen
genauso wie jeder für sich sonst für
seine gesundheit der stadt hat alles
getan impfstoffe medikamente sind da
unten gesundheitswesen er kann nicht
mehr machen vielen dank so weit erst mal
hersteller für dieses statement sie
sprechen gleich nochmal jetzt wollen uns
aber zusammen mal anschauen wie im
bundestag debattiert wurde gestern sehr
emotional und auch heute vor der
abstimmung ging es hoch her hier auszüge
aus der debatte
die pannen hieß leider noch nicht vorbei
und wir brauchen weitere schutzmaßnahmen
und um solche zu beschließen sind wir
heute zusammengekommen wir haben viel
geschafft aber wir sind nicht an dem
punkt wo schon an freedom day kommen
könnte wären wir uns heute die
fallzahlen anschauen fast 300.000 fälle
werden wir uns heute die todeszahlen
anschauen über 200 menschen sind
gestorben das kann uns nicht
zufriedenstellen das ist extrem
unbefriedigend dazu kommt die deutsche
sonderrolle die über 60 jährigen zu
einem hohen maß
um games viel mehr als in unseren
nachbarländern und wir haben darüber
hinaus eine relativ alte bevölkerung
daher brauchen wir schutzmaßnahmen
schutzmaßnahmen die in anderen ländern
in diesem umfang nicht mehr notwendig
sind wir sprechen heute über einen
schweren kompromiss das ist aber nicht
der kompromiss das ist nicht der
kompromiss über den wir heute sprechen
zwischen team freiheit und den vorsicht
sondern wir sprechen heute über einen
kompromiss
was können wir den menschen noch zumuten
die sich all die zahl an die regeln
halten und unsere kinder was was können
wir den menschen noch zumuten die die
regeln beachten und was sind wir bereit
denjenigen zuzumuten die gar nichts
bereits so sind zu opfern die sich nicht
impfen überfällig wasser nicht aus die
außer störend einen einzigen
konstruktiven beitrag jeden fall auch in
der gesamten fanden bisher haben leisten
können die regelungen die wir heute
vorstellen ist eine regelung die
folgende tatsache rechnung stellt ja
durch die omikron variante nicht mehr
die situation dass das gesamte land
gefährdet ist in dem sinne dass wir eine
überlastung dass wir eine überlastung
der kliniken dass wir eine überlassung
der kliniken flächendeckend zu
befürchten haben trotzdem würde es so
sagen dass in vielen stellen tatsächlich
genau diese überlastung kommen wird und
da haben wir die regeln angepasst dass
überall dort wo wir eine überlastung der
krankenhäuser und der
gesundheitsversorgung erwarten müssen
dass dort die hotspot regelung zählt und
wir werden auch weitergehende maßnahmen
ergreifen können und wo das nicht der
fall ist wird es nicht gemacht darauf
haben wir uns angepasst ich finde das
schon bemerkenswert der kollege
lauterbach wenn sie sich hier hinstellen
und sagen in der koalition sei einigkeit
darüber erzeugt wurden was hot spots
sind also ich habe jetzt ihren
bundesjustizminister nicht klatschen
sehen bei der sieht das offensichtlich
ganz anders als sie was ein hotspot sein
kann also insofern wenn sie schon nicht
einig sind dann müssen sie sich nicht
wundern wenn die länder nicht wissen wie
sie das umsetzen
und ich kann ihnen ganz klar sagen wir
haben ja gestern die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz der länder
gehabt es ist ein absolutes novum in der
geschichte dass 16 ministerpräsident und
ministerpräsidenten dieser
bundesrepublik deutschland in
protokollerklärungen sagen dass das so
nicht geht dass das wirrwarr erzeugt
dass die ampel auf rot gelb grün steht
und im grunde das chaos mit ansage ist
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sie sagen
in bereichen wo besonders hohe neue
infektionen kommen kann reagiert werden
keiner weiß was meinen sie mit besonders
hohem neuinfektionen und die drohende
klinik überlastung im hinblick auf die
hotspots das ist genau der punkt der
maßgebliche punkt den sie innerhalb der
koalition nicht geklärt haben der
kollege lauterbach und da sollten sie
dringend nacharbeiten aus meiner sicht
als ärztin als gesundheitspolitikerin
aus meiner fraktion und im übrigen auch
der mehrheit der bevölkerung braucht es
für einen guten infektionsschutz
vermutlich mehr als das was heute in
diesem gesetz vorliegt fr
wir wissen dass er wie zwei masken einen
guten schutz vor ansteckung bieten und
es wäre gut weiterhin präventiv zu
addieren und die masken pflicht
flächendeckend beizubehalten
und es ist kein geheimnis dass wir auch
innerhalb der koalition unterschiedliche
positionen dazu hatten welche maßnahmen
jetzt bundesweit weiterhin nötig sind
aber
kein gesetz wer sehr viel schlechter
gewesen als dieses gesetz was ja
weiterhin
schutzmaßnahmen beinhaltet
und darum werden wir als bündnis 90 die
grünen auch zustimmen auch wenn wir uns
deutlich mehr gewünscht hätten weil das
ist das was innerhalb der ampel
vereinbar war und worst case wäre
gewesen alle schutzmaßnahmen auslaufen
zu lassen hier also mit diesem gesetz
schützen wir natürlich mehr als ohne
gesetz hier ist der spatz in der hand
natürlich deutlich mehr schutz als die
taube auf dem dach dieser entwurf auf
den so viele menschen sehnsüchtig warten
weil sie endlich wieder normal wieder
frei leben wollen ist nichts weiter als
eine beruhigungspille
denn die wenigen erleichterungen können
jederzeit aufgehoben werden ganz nach
lust und laune
da ist keine eindeutigen parameter für
die hotspots gibt die krone maßnahmen
hören schon deshalb komplett vom tisch
weil das dafür erhobene kriterium zu
keinem zeitpunkt erfüllt war zu keinem
zeitpunkt gab es eine überlastung der
krankenhäuser oder der intensivstation
nicht die freiheit von einschränkungen
des begründung bedürftig die
einschränkung der freiheit ist
begründung bedürftig und das müssen wir
bei jeder bei jeder einzelnen maßnahmen
die wir treffen immer wieder vor augen
haben wir müssen wir müssen dafür sorgen
dass wir politik so ausgestalten dass
nur das an den wenigen freiheits
einschränkungen möglich ist das
notwendig ist und das ist das was wir
mit diesem gesetzesentwurf dass das was
wir mit diesem vorschlag schon
geschützen auf der einen seite sorgen
aber dafür dass wir so weit wie es
irgendwie geht zurück zur normalität
kommen
die herausforderung vor der wir stehen
ist natürlich dass sich pandemie
geschehen das sich aber auch wissen
entwickelt und so war es ja ganz klar
dass vor dem schleier der unwissenheit
am anfang der pandemie entscheidung
getroffen wurden bei denen wir heute
sagen sie waren damals falsch diese idee
dieses gesetz
so zu auszugestalten dass wir auf der
einen seite schutz bei hotspots haben
und auf der anderen seite
dafür sorgen dass die menschen in den
alltag zurückfinden dass die menschen
ihre verantwortung umsetzen und ihrer
verantwortung gerecht werden können das
ist es was wir politisch einfordern
müssen denn meine damen und herren die
menschen in deutschland sind ja keine
kleinen kinder wir verbieten niemanden
masken zu tragen wir ermöglichen den
menschen ihre eigene verantwortung
selbst die hand nehmen und das tue gern
auch einer liberal die bundesregierung
möchte gerne die fortschritts koalition
seien aber was bitte ist daran
fortschrittlich dauernd gesetze im
schweinsgalopp durch das parlament zu
treiben die dann auch noch handwerklich
und inhaltlich schlecht sind
beim infektionsschutz das haben wir
jetzt seit zwei jahren und die ampel die
top tatsächlich auch noch die groko nur
den pflege bonus den haben sie nicht
innerhalb einer woche hinbekommen an dem
doktor sie jetzt seit monaten herum das
ist peinlich meine damen und herren
omikron verursacht zum glück weniger
schwere verläufe und ja die
ausgangssituation ist eine andere als
vor zwei jahren aber bei einem
höchststand an infektionen und bei
täglichen longo bit und todesfällen
lockert man doch nicht von 100 auf
nahezu null
zu gunsten der freedom day partei
genannt fdp geben bundesregierung und
gesundheitsminister der ansonsten der
ewige mahner in der panini gewesen ist
hier eine politische bankrotterklärung
ab
ihre regionale hotspot regel geschafft
einen flickenteppich an
unterschiedlichen maßnahmen sie lassen
damit die bundesländer im regen stehen
und sie fördern auch noch den föderalen
überbietung und unterbietungswettbewerb
das ist wirklich absurd meine damen und
herren herr stöhr wir haben die debatte
im bundestag heute gehört sie waren ja
schon früh dafür vieles zu lockern die
finden sie das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz da kommt ja
spielt und bleibt da nicht hinter dem
zurück weil es international eigentlich
nicht mehr unser nachbar länder haben
vorgemacht irgendwann hat im letzten
jahr schon einen zeitpunkt eingeführt wo
man fast alles gemüse gelockert hat die
ideen damit im oktober letzten jahres
vorgemacht und immer wieder gesagt wenn
es die situation verschlechtern dann
passen wir wieder an in europa gibt es
fast kein land weiß nicht schon mal
vorher und umfassend gelockert hat also
es kommt ja spät und jetzt tatsächlich
gibt es noch ein parteien die mehr
wollen man darf ja nicht vergessen
letztendlich ist
auf dem weg hin zum pandemie ende das
infektionsrisiko dass einzelne schon
klar werde ich geimpft wird sich
infizieren wir unglücklich infizieren
und ja das ergebnis dieser infektion ist
steht auch schon fest es hängt eben vom
eigenen wunsch eindeutigen
gesundheitsstatus ab ob man sich jetzt
infiziert in drei wochen oder einem
halben jahr spielt keine rolle und war
das gesundheitssystem nicht überlastet
ist das allgemeinwohl nicht gefährdet
ist ist es jetzt vernünftiger eine
steile kopie zu haben die kurze ist als
eine lange wo man jeder infektion nach
hinten schiebt das war ja richtig
inspektion nach hinten zu schieben als
es noch keinen impfstoff dann hat man
gewappnet natürlich jene stoffe
eingeführt jeder kann sich jetzt
schützen das uns schutz kriegen wir
nicht als jetzt mehr impfstoffe gibt es
nicht besser besseres gesundheitssystem
gibt es nicht und gärtner medikamente
und jeder muss jetzt ruhig durch die
infektion man kann immer weiter noch mal
hinten schieben und deutschland ihr auf
dem paralleluniversum alle anderen haben
sich entschieden dass zügig durch die
stehen mit einem soliden
gesundheitswesens ja ganz wichtig aber
in deutschland gibt es immer noch leute
die kinder wie masken aufsetzen wollen
in brandenburg hat man jetzt entschieden
dem die masten kriegt bei kindern zu
beizubehalten dreimal pro woche zu test
man kein geld auch gleich verbrennen
also es macht keinen sinn mehr jetzt
wirklich die infektion unterschieden
weil jeder sicher infizieren wird das
ist in deutschland besonders schwierig
natürlich umzusetzen weil die angstmache
über monate jahre ja auch von einigen
politik und besonders geführt wurde und
wenn man in europa reiste da wir einmal
kurz ein haken sie haben zwei länder
zitiert die eine ganz andere impfquote
haben in dänemark ist die sehr viel
höher als bei uns und auch die
bevölkerungsstrukturen sind ja
unterschiedlich sowohl in großbritannien
als auch in dänemark jetzt wollte ich
sie ganz gerne fragen was ist denn mit
den zweit und dritt infektionen es ist
ja mit einer infektion gar nicht getan
also da kann man ja nicht dafür
plädieren es einfach laufen zu lassen
also die impfraten in dänemark auch in
england in frankreich in der schweiz
denn vergleicht man bei den
übersichtlich und lassen sich die
entscheidende gruppe 99 prozent bei den
über 50 jährigen eine vergleichbare der
immunisierung tragenden deutsche jahr in
deutschland 91 prozent 92 drängen sich
40 prozent
nicht schon erwähnt habe der unterschied
ist gering und jetzt dass ich ja
anzuführen ist er auch herr lauterbach
sagte ihr könnt nicht öffnen weil die
anderen hören in frage das passt nicht
zu den zahlen zwar
kurz noch eine eine nachfrage zu der
masken pflicht was was stört sie daran
ist meine maske schützen uns alle etwas
p2 masken gibt es ja auch für kinder in
kindergröße was ist daran so verkehr das
ihrer
68 getan möchte das gern tun das ist
völlig falsch aber von staatlicher seite
jetzt leute zu zwingen eine maske zu
tragen manch verhindert ja nichts wenn
ich jetzt noch mal ausgetragen würde und
mich jetzt nicht in den nächsten wochen
einem halben jahr infizieren wird für
mich das erkrankungsrisiko identisch
bleiben das ist für die kinder für die
gesunden erwachsenen und wir auch schon
die erkrankten genau dasselbe man
verschiebt das problem immer weiter nur
nach hinten hat es deshalb franken sind
bereits eine frage seine noch gestartet
sie lassen ein bisschen außer acht was
mit longo wird ist das betrifft ja sehr
viele menschen die sich auch geimpft
dann infiziert haben mit dem virus wie
gehen sie damit um
tragisch für den einzelnen der janko
wird bekommt ist das natürlich fraglich
aber nochmal auch das kann nicht
verhindert werden dann medikament sagen
sie mir eine infektionskontrolle sagen
eine maßnahme mit der man verhindern
kann dass ich nicht alle infizierten
eine eine letzte frage mit einer etwas
mit einer bitte um eine kürzere antwort
wofür würden sie plädieren wenn wir es
in der pandemie wieder mit einer
gefährlichen virusvariante zu tun
bekommen
wenn sie neue pandemie gibt muss man
steinenstadt entwickeln die infektion so
weit wie möglich ein schieben die
maßnahmen auf die konzentrieren die
höchste risiko haben die über 60
jährigen also und altenpflegeheim und
wenn dann die alle maßnahmen
ausgeschöpft so wie jetzt man die
sektion eines jeden nicht verändern kann
dann muss man auch wieder realisieren
dass die pandemie auswirkungen alle sich
infiziert haben hersteller ich danke
ihnen für das gespräch und für ihre zeit
zu sagen wie schön